THERE COME OVER THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES WILL BE DOING JUST
THAT.
BUT FIRST, I’VE BEEN WANTING FOR
WEEKS AND WEEKS TO KEEP AN EYE
ON THE CORONAVIRUS THAT IS
SPREADING FROM CHINA TO
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
MY CONCERN WAS I DIDN’T TRUST
WHAT CHINA WAS SAYING ABOUT IT.
SOME BREAKING NEWS TO REPORT ON
THE VIRUS TONIGHT.
THE U.S. MILITARY JUST ANNOUNCED
MOMENTS AGO THAT ONE OF ITS
SOLDIERS BASED IN SOUTH KOREA,
THEY TESTED POSITIVE FOR THIS
NEW VIRUS.
THE FIRST U.S. SERVICE MEMBER TO
BE INFECTED.
NOW, I’M GOING TO TAKE YOU
THROUGH HOW ALL OF THIS UNFOLDED
TODAY.
AT ROUGHLY NOON, WITH THE
PRESIDENT OUT OF THE COUNTRY,
THE CDC BEGAN SOUNDING THIS
ALARM.
>> DISRUPTION TO EVERYDAY LIFE
MAY BE SEVERE.
BUT THESE ARE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO START THINKING ABOUT
NOW.
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
I WOULD SAY RIGHTFULLY SO.
I’M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
CDC IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
>> Laura: WELL, IN INDIA, WITH
THE MARKETS -- THE PRESIDENT WAS
IN INDIA, AND THE MARKETS
PLUMMETING, BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS SPREAD COME ALL THAT
ACCELERATING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO ADDRESSED
THE THREAT.
>> WE ARE WORKING WITH CHINA
VERY MUCH ON THE VIRUS.
WE FEEL THAT SOMETHING -- AND I
HAVE TO TELL, I SPOKE TO
PRESIDENT XI THE OTHER DAY.
HE IS SO COMMITTED TO SOLVING
THAT PROBLEM.
HE WAS WORKING VERY HARD.
HE IS VERY CAPABLE.
THE COUNTRY IS VERY CAPABLE.
IT SNUCK UP ON THEM, BUT I THINK
HE IS GOING TO DO WELL.
>> Laura: SNUCK UP ON THEM?
I DON’T KNOW WHAT TO SAY ABOUT
THAT.
IT WAS MEASURED AND IT WAS
DIPLOMATIC, AND HE IS ON THE
WORLD STAGE, SO WE LIKE THAT.
BUT I SURE WOULDN’T TRUST CHINA
ON THIS ISSUE AT ALL, FOR
STARTERS, WE STILL DON’T
KNOW WHAT SPARKED OF THIS
EPIDEMIC.
CHINESE CENSORS HAVE BEEN
SCRUBBING THE INTERNET OF ANY
REAL INFORMATION OF WHAT IS
GOING ON WITHIN THEIR OWN
BORDERS.
BUT DON’T COUNT ON THE W.H.O.
FOR ANY HELP ON THIS.
THEY ARE BASICALLY COMPLICIT, IN
MY VIEW, IN WHAT CHINA HAS BEEN
DOING TO COVER THIS UP.
>> DO WE LOOK AT, OKAY, THE REST
OF THE WORLD WOULD BE ACCESS THE
EXPERTISE OF CHINA.
THEY’VE DONE THIS AT SCALE.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
AND THEY ARE REALLY, REALLY GOOD
AT IT.
THEY ARE REALLY KEEN TO HELP.
IF I HAD IT, I WOULD WANT TO BE
HELPED IN CHINA.
>> Laura: YOU CAN STAY IN
CHINA IF IT IS SO FUN OVER
THERE.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS, THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM HAVE TO
PREPARE FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF
OUTBREAKS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT IS A VIRUS, AND VIRUSES
TRAVEL.
TODAY, HE’S WORKING GROUP WAS
BACK IN WASHINGTON, AND IT GOT
INTO THE SPECIFICS.
>> THE IMMEDIATE RISK TO THE
GENERAL AMERICAN PUBLIC REMAINS
LOW.
BUT AS WE HAVE WARNED, THAT HAD
THE POTENTIAL TO CHANGE QUICKLY.
THERE IS NO COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION IN A NUMBER OF
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING OUTSIDE OF
ASIA.
THAT IS DEEPLY CONCERNING.
>> THE USUAL AND APPROPRIATE
CARE FOR MOST PATIENTS TO
DEVELOP NOVEL CORONAVIRUS OR
COVID-19, WOULD BE MANAGEMENT AT
HOME, THROUGH HOME ISOLATION,
WITH USE OF HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ONLY AS NEEDED FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE SEVERE
PRESENTATION.
>> Laura: WATCHING THE MEDIA
COVERAGE TODAY, IT SEEMED LIKE
SOME OF THE TRUMP HATERS WERE
ACTUALLY RELISHING IN THIS
MOMENT.
A NEW AVENUE, CORONAVIRUS, THAT
IS A NEW PATHWAY FOR HITTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HOW SICK THAT THESE PEOPLE SEEM
ALMOST HAPPIEST WHEN AMERICANS
ARE HURTING.
AND, OF COURSE, OUR MARKETS ARE
FEELING THE PAIN.
NOW, THE SELL-OFF HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT, AND FRANKLY, IT
COULD CONTINUE AS THE INFECTION
RATE GROWS AROUND THE WORLD AND
IN THE UNITED STATES, WE HAVE SU
CHAIN DISRUPTION.
NONE OF THAT SHOULD BE
SURPRISING AT THIS POINT.
BUT WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION’S
MESSAGING ONHIS HAS BEEN
LACKING, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
DISGUSTING THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SEEKING TO USE THIS COMPLEX
VIRUS TO SCORE CHEAP POLITICAL
POINTS.
AFTER THEY KNOW MIKE AND
POLITICALLY DISASTROUS
IMPEACHMENT AND THE FIERCE
INTERPARTY FIGHTING THAT WE’LL
GET INTO IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS,
DEMOCRATS NEEDED TO CHANGE THE S
AND FAST, AND SO, LIKE THE
CORONAVIRUS ITSELF, DEMOCRATS
AND FRIENDS MOVED TO QUICKLY
INFECT THE POLITICAL DISCUSSION
WITH VIRAL RECRIMINATIONS.
>> SENDERS FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE TODAY SUGGESTED THAT
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUESTING TO COMBAT THIS,
$2.5 BILLION, THAT IS
INSUFFICIENT.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY CUTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROPOSED TO THESE
VARIOUS PREPAREDNESS PROGRAMS.
>> THERE HAS BEEN SORT OF A
HOLLOWING OUT OF THESE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITIES IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE.
>> Laura: OKAY, THE CDC’S
BUDGET WAS MORE THAN $7 BILLION
IN 2019.
IF THAT’S NOT ENOUGH TO PREPARE
FOR A GLOBAL EPIDEMIC, THEY NEED
TO DO SOME SERIOUS HOUSECLEANING
AT THE CDC.
PLUS, TRUMP IS REQUESTING THAT
2.5 BILLION YOU JUST HEARD
ABOUT, TO DEAL WITH THE
OUTBREAK.
IF THE SENATE BELIEVES WE SHOULD
HAVE MORE?
GUESS WHAT, THE SENATE AND
APPROPRIATE MOTOR WITH THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES WORKING
TOGETHER.
BUT YOU CAN THROW FACTS LIKE
THAT AT THE LEFT ALL DAY LONG,
NONE OF IT WOULD MATTER.
TRUMP COULD PERSONALLY GO TO
CHINA TO FIND SOME TYPE OF CURE
OR FIND OUT WHO PATIENT 0 WAS,
AND STILL SAY THINGS LIKE THIS.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY CONFIDENCE
THAT HE WILL JUST ARBITRARILY
SHUT DOWN ENTRY FROM ITALY?
NEW YORKERS, OR SOMEONE FROM
KANSAS GHOST ITALY?
>> I WOULD NEVER BET THAT
DONALD TRUMP WILL NOT DO
ANYTHING THAT IS OUTSIDE OF THE
NORM.
>> IF YOU ARE SO INTO AMERICAN
ISOLATIONISM AND YOU ARE
THINKING IT IS AMERICA FIRST,
THERE ARE CERTAIN PROBLEMS WHICH
ARE REALLY GLOBAL.
THEY HAVE TO BE SOLVED BY HAVING
ALL OF THESE COUNTRIES COME
TOGETHER.
THAT DOESN’T WORK WITH SAYING
AMERICA FIRST.
>> Laura: NICE JOB, ANDY,
STICK WITH SCREWING UP THE LAW.
ANY MORE PEOPLE TO COME INTO THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE INFECTED.
WHAT A BUFFOON.
DOES ANYBODY ACTUALLY THINK THAT
MORE GLOBALISM IS GOING TO HELP
THIS CRISIS?
YOU WANT TO COOPERATE, FOR SURE,
BUT BRINGING MORE PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES, DON’T HAVE ANY
CONCERN ABOUT HER TRAVELS WHERE,
IS THAT WHAT THEY WERE STAYING
OVER AT MSNBC TODAY?
BECAUSE I’M REALLY CONFUSED
LISTENING TO THAT LOGIC THAT
GOES ALL OVER THE PLACE.
NOW, FOR NOW, THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS TO IGNORE THE POLITICAL
HACKS WHO ARE VYING FOR AIRTIME
AND LISTEN TO ACTUAL EXPERTS.
HE HAS ASSEMBLED A PHENOMENAL
TEAM TO TACKLE THE CORONAVIRUS.
NOW, THIS MAY END UP BEING A